[Musique]
parmi les infos qu'il ne fallait pas
louper aujourd'hui on revient sur cette
affaire une professeur de danse qui
était écarté de Sciences Po Paris après
des plaintes d'étudiants si des
étudiants de la prestigieuse école de
Sciences Po peuvent apprendre le droit
l'économie ou encore la politique ils
peuvent aussi s'inscrire à des cours de
danse
depuis une trentaine d'années Valérie
enseigne la danse de salon mais elle est
donc aujourd'hui dans la tourmente à
cause de cette phrase prononcée à ses
élèves j'ai dit les garçons d'un côté
les filles de l'autre enfoncés par ces
propos certains étudiants se sont alors
plein de discrimination auprès de
l'établissement un élève a porté plainte
en disant qu'il avait été mis mal à
l'aise sur quoi donc décidé de l'écarter
pour son comportement jugé sexiste mais
la professeur de danse qui a refusé les
duos du même sexe se défend et à terme
pourtant ne pas avoir été discriminante
je pense pas que ça soit une insulte
c'est un mot dans le dictionnaire
français alors comprenez vous quel était
sanctionnée
incroyable incroyable histoire encore
incroyable histoire qui comprend quel
était sanctionnée à Gilles Verdez
là
en fait moi je trouve que ça va ça va
devenir très très compliqué d'être
moderne d'être inclusif d'être avec son
temps parce que je trouve que
franchement le tango voilà il y a rien
de méchant dans ce cadeau
aujourd'hui à Sciences Po il règne une
terreur moi j'ai parlé avec des élèves
aujourd'hui à Sciences Po donc d'abord
elle n'a pas été viré elle est partie
donc déjà élément de langage et ensuite
les élèves ne voulaient pas me parler
parce qu'ils avaient très très peur que
je puisse éventuellement dire qu'il
règne une terreur aujourd'hui à Sciences
Po avec des associations comme ça qui le
walking avec plus d'hommes plus de
femmes plus hétéro plus haut enfin c'est
juste on marche sur la tête et je trouve
que ça fait beaucoup de mal
quoi qu'est-ce qu'il y a mais moi je
suis très content
mais bien évidemment
elle a refusé que des couples hommes et
des couples femmes dansent ensemble vous
entendez Cyril ça c'est pas possible si
c'est le cas ça c'est pas possible c'est
pas ça
que c'était moche de femmes qui dansent
bien sûr
elle a été quand même dans cette affaire
mais c'est parti
on fait leader followers pour se trouver
un système qui lui permettait de rester
elle a refusé tous les élèves tous les
élèves ont été choqués les frères on
peut plus rien dire alors les gars les
garçons d'à côté les filles de l'autre
c'est pas moi qui danse ensemble c'est
catastrophique ou deux femmes qui
dansent ensemble
elle a dit les
mais même ça Cyril c'est discriminant ça
veut dire ça veut dire que deux hommes
ou deux femmes ne peuvent pas danser
ensemble à l'école les garçons d'un côté
les finances
la manière dont elle le dit je peux dire
le mot c'est ça non mais le dis même pas
tu me fatigues moi j'ai été prof
s du coup j'ai de pas être bien réveillé
et c'est ce qu'elle aurait dû dire j'ai
dit allez les filles d'un garçon les
côtés de l'autre toi et là j'ai rien eu
pas de blâme rien
merci Jean-Marie merci bah écoute je
peux aider hein
pas bien bien aidé
bravo
à cet enseignante qui a su résister au
walkisme insupportable de Sciences Po et
moi ça me fait peur parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'on veut détruire toutes
les cultures pour faire plaisir à
quelques personnes je vois pardon là
encore sur les réseaux sociaux quel est
taxé d'homophobe je pense que ça n'a
rien à voir sinon ça voudrait dire quoi
que parce qu'on est homosexuel on doit
nécessairement danser avec un homme
parce qu'on est homosexuel ça n'a pas de
sens pourquoi tout ramener à la
sexualité en permanence et je pense que
même les étudiants sont foutent ils font
juste si
on terrorisé tout le monde de tout et
n'importe quoi et bravo elle d'avoir
résisté à ça voilà franchement et ça
fait peur tout ça qui est d'accord avec
là qui est personne à part Gilles Verdun
Raymond Quest à dire à Gilles bon moi
j'ai rien à dire agi c'est juste que on
peut pas on peut pas rentrer à chaque
fois comment
il a raison si lui il pense ça mais si
on reste que sur ces images là et pas ce
qui s'est dit que elle voulait pas que
les deux hommes danse ensemble les deux
femmes dans son ensemble ne doit pas
elle doit pas se faire licencer que pour
se motif là pour moi c'est pas assez tu
veux pas les gens
on reste là-dessus pour moi c'est non
elle doit pas être licenciée
pas trop de donner la parole aujourd'hui
ça va te faire du bien peut-être l'air
frais non mais je rigole Matthieu bah
pour apprendre à Guillaume qui pense que
je ramène tout le temps tout à
l'homosexualité les Asos homosexuels en
général ne tombe plutôt dessus mais que
Bilal je m'étais pris à lui parce qu'en
général si tu écoutes un peu l'émission
quand tu dors pas tu verras qu'en
général c'est plutôt souvent de de tu as
besoin d'une bonne ambiance
non mais j'aime pas quand tout d'un coup
il vit un peu racaille et tout tu as pas
de couilles
un bisou après j'aime bien attaque le
maintenant ok allez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il sera vraiment malade il aura le covid
[Rires]
alors moi je suis un petit peu vieille
France mais je alors s'il y a bien sûr
il y a eu des propos homophobes et tout
mais ça c'était pas dans la salle en
revanche moi je suis un petit peu
vieille France et je trouve que c'est
joli un garçon et une fille qui dansent
ensemble moi je suis pas fan de voir
deux filles danser ensemble ou deux
garçons
voilà il y a un truc dans la danse qui
est assez traditionnel que je trouve
plutôt plutôt jolie et dans un cours
comme ça les gens font ce qu'ils veulent
chez eux mais dans un cours comme ça je
trouve que la danse il y a un côté
séduction effectivement qui est homme
femme et que et que et que j'ai dit
alors Delphine
non mais au départ le tango c'est des
hommes qui dansent ensemble avant
d'aller au bordel c'est ça la tradition
au début
[Applaudissements]
on a passé la non je veux pas danser
dans l'air de pas c'est bon je suis
attendu voilà oui Delphine moi je trouve
que il y a plein de il y a plein
d'évolution positives qui aujourd'hui
mettent trop de temps à se mettre en
place notamment bien sûr l'écologie
notamment la cause animale notamment ce
qui se passe dans les hôpitaux notamment
ce qui se passe à l'école et il y a des
surévolutions sur ce domaine là qui est
au final c'est au final totalement
contre-productif quand on ne peut même
dire c'est une fille c'est un garçon
donc voilà il y a des choses sur
lesquelles on prend du temps à évoluer
et il y a des choses c'est c'est
n'importe quoi c'est ça en devient
régressif et ça met ça met les gens dans
l'embarras et tout moi j'ai du mal à
croire qu'elle est juste été virée parce
qu'elle a dit il y a des garçons
ils disent qu'elle a été viré mais c'est
pas